Оголошення українською мовою...
(звучить оголошення) "Увага! Другий дзвоник. Розпочинається урок.
…а на уроках лунає переважно російська.
"Светит светлая луна..." (діти співають)
Це першокласники 25-ої школи Києва -
однієї з восьми шкіл столиці з російською мовою викладання.
Діти навчаються за програмою Нової української школи.
Держава забезпечила їх новими партами, стільцями,
ось цими підручниками, зошитами та відеоуроками,
спеціально розробленими для шкіл
із поглибленим вивченням російської мови.
Ще два роки тому у школі було 23 класи з викладанням російською.
Тепер їх 20. Три початкові класи вже перейшли
на викладання державною мовою.
Такі зміни передбачені новим Законом про державну мову
і новим Законом про освіту. Відповідно
до цих законів, школа має й далі збільшувати
кількість годин викладання українською.
Ці першокласники, відповідно до програми НУШ,
мають щотижня 5 годин усного курсу української мови.
Діти прийшли до школи здебільшого з російськомовних родин.
Утім, як зазначає їхня вчителька Олександра Олександрівна,
в умовах збільшення вжитку української мови
в усіх сферах життя діти особливих проблем
із її засвоєнням не мають.
- Діти краще знають українську мову, бо вони її більше чують.
І по телебаченню, і деякі слова, які раніше ми пояснювали,
вони все вже багато разів чули і в рекламах якихось…
Олександра Олександрівна у школі 30 років,
випустила вже більше десяти класів
і в усіх викладала російською.
Відповідно до нового Закону про освіту,
з вересня 2020 року всі школи України
мають переходити на державну мову викладання.
Олександра Олександрівна, як і усі вчителі цієї школи,
пройшла відповідні курси підвищення кваліфікації,
тож каже, що готова й сама перейти, і справжню
українськомовну атмосферу на уроках створити.
Якщо раніше їй доводилося перекладати
українськомовні навчальні плакати російською мовою,
то тепер усе буде навпаки.
- А наступного року всю цю інформацію для дітей,
що в нас можна робити в класі,
- те, що було написано російською мовою, -
ми будемо перекладати українською.
На відміну від першачків, які легко засвоюють українську мову,
старшокласникам перехід, імовірно, даватиметься важче.
Цей 8-й клас прийшов до школи ще у 2012 році.
Більшість предметів усі роки вони вивчали російською.
Наразі щотижня вони мають 21 годину російською,
7 годин - державною мовою.
Із наступного року все зміниться з точністю до навпаки.
Вчителька російської мови й заступниця директора школи
Наталія Гура не впевнена, що дітям буде легко
зробити такий різкий перехід, приміром, у вивченні алгебри чи фізики.
І дуже сподівається на допомогу міносвіти: принаймні, на роз’яснення.
- Якщо нам скажуть, яким чином це
буде відбуватися, то я думаю, що треба буде...
вчителі-предметники повинні будуть готувати дітей
з зими, ось зараз, із цього періоду.
Терміни, наприклад, називати російською і українською мовою,
як і відбувається, в принципі.
Має бути якийсь адаптаційний період,
який  дозволить дитині звикнути до цього.
Додаткового адаптаційного періоду для шкіл
із викладанням російської наразі не передбачається.
Це в інтерв’ю DW чітко дала зрозуміти
міністерка освіти та науки Ганна Новосад.
- Російська буде викладатися як факультатив.
Відповідно до закону про освіту і перехідних положень,
із вересня наступного року усі мови...
усі школи, перепрошую,  мають перейти  на українську мову викладання.
Така позиція міністерства не подобається
багатьом батькам 25-ї школи. У ній навчаються
близько сотні дітей, які вимушені були переїхати до Києва
через анексію Криму і війну на сході України.
Ольга народилася на Донеччині, давно мешкає в Києві
й перевезла сюди з-під обстрілів своїх дітей та онуків.
Обрала для них школу, де викладають саме російською,
яку вона називає своєю рідною.
- Мій онук знає українську на відмінно, любить її.
Але ми від народження знаємо "русскій язик".
Не "россійскій", а "русскій".
Дивно, що наші інтереси як нацменшин ніхто не відстоює.
Тільки тому, що в нас війна з Росією,
не потрібна війна з російською мовою.
Багато батьків погоджуються з Ольгою.
Аби зберегти мову, якою вони спілкуються вдома,
дехто згоден навіть возити сюди дітей із віддалених районів Києва.
Вони переконані: влада має забезпечити їхнє право
як національної меншини отримувати освіту
російською мовою.
Однак за законом російськомовні громадяни України,
на відміну від, приміром, угорців та румунів,
не є національною меншиною.
- Справа в тому, що дійсно наші батьки
не можуть підтвердити, що вони є національною меншиною.
Вони приходять до школи через те, що  самі
закінчували цю школу, їхні батьки навчалися
чи вони просто хотіли, щоб дитина отримувала
освіту російською мовою.
А підтверджуючих документів, які говорять про те,
що це є нацменшина, що є самоврядування,
цього немає.
Учителі школи налаштовані багато працювати з батьками,
аби без зайвих емоцій подолати перехід на державну мову.
Особливо важко буде тим батькам,  які не знають
української мови чи принципово не хочуть її знати.
Щоправда, більшість опитаних DW батьків не проти того,
щоб їхні діти вивчали українську і володіли нею.
За умови, що і російська залишиться.
- Ми з дружиною говоримо російською. Я з Донецька.
Я тільки за те, щоб була українська мова,
щоб її вивчали. Можна робити так, щоб щодня був
урок українською, але щоб діти спілкувалися російською.
- Чом би й ні. Всі ж спілкуються  російською,
чому б не вивчати українську.
- Ми, звісно, більше схиляємося до вивчення російської.
Українська мова як державна, безумовно, теж потрібна.
В цій школі російська йде на рівні з державною.
- Екзамени здають на українській мові. Так що, в принципі, не проблема абсолютно.
- А що, є вибір? Байдуже, готові ми чи ні. Програми затверджені? Все.
Саме відсутність вибору найбільше обурює батьків.
- Має бути якийсь діалог із нами. Діалогу не було.
Держава вирішила
і вирішила попередня влада.
Батьківський комітет цієї школи розраховує, що
партії Володимира Зеленського вдасться вчергове
відтермінувати перехід шкіл із поглибленим вивченням російської
на українську мову викладання.
Наразі в парламенті саме зареєстровано законопроект,
який передбачає збільшення перехідного періоду
для переходу на державну мову викладання до 2023-го року.